so jayden as you undermine my behavior
just like my whole family always has
with
i hope she gets better i will pray for
her
pray for what
britney spears clapping back at her son
jaden do you guys want me to get better
so i can continue to give your dad 40
grand a month
or the reasoning behind you guys
deciding to be hateful is because it's
actually over in two years and you don't
get anything
the singer shared a new audio recording
on instagram reacting to her 15 year
old's recent 60 minutes australia
interview where he opened up about their
strained relationship and even defended
his grandfather jamie spears for placing
brittany under a conservatorship at
first i mean everyone is mostly hitting
him for the conservatorship right but
i think at first he was just trying to
be like any father like pursue her
daughter's dream of like being a
superstar and working and going and all
these uh concerts and performing but um
i think some people are just like
ceasing to realize how much he cares
about her
brick caught wind of what jaden said and
yeah she's not having it i know i'm not
perfect but the love i've given you and
how much i adore you in your diplomatic
ways speaking like paw paw
self entitled this can be fixed i will
see her when she's better jayden it was
a miracle i could even have a normal
conversation when i got out of that
place but you were just like my other
family you secretly
loved looking at me as something was
wrong with me
i didn't need a family hiding in houses
and whispering behind my back feeling
subconsciously guilty because i paid for
everything in both homes
the pop star also goes into detail about
her past visits with jaden and his
brother preston before they became
estranged i sat in that kitchen and
looked you straight in that eyes
beautiful boy and said how come i can't
see you guys anymore
or just see you guys more i look forward
to seeing you seeing you guys weekly
you said mama oh it'll change you and
your brother left me in that house
always two hours early
preston would sleep you would play the
piano the whole time and if i didn't
shower you guys with gifts and have
amazing food ready and play a
[ __ ] saint it was still never
good enough
and brittany she thinks the reason for
jaden's interview has something to do
with money
do you guys want me to get better so i
can continue to give your dad 40 grand a
month
or is the reasoning behind you guys
deciding to be hateful is because it's
actually over in two years and you don't
get anything i needed unconditional love
and support but guess what the whole
twist of it all
which would have made a little bit more
sense
i was in the greatest state i'd ever
been because i was actually able to
speak up 100 and say no
britt's voice note ends on a solemn note
telling fans she's lost her sense of
faith
honestly my dad needs to be in jail for
the rest of his life
but like i said
god would not allow that to happen to me
if a god existed
i don't believe in god anymore because
of the way my children and my family
have treated me there is nothing to
believe anymore
i'm an atheist y'all
you